[Música]
ah
me late
el poder
de mango
[Música]
decimos
me mata
su tema
[Música]
demanda
i
[Música]
louis
dime
[Música]
y ahí es que pudimos
en ambos sistemas
y después de lalín
soledad
de mante
kim jong y el lema para ti
ya venía ghanés a mí
si te ml de mano
bueno
[Música]
la vida gas y agua
si llamas
demás
más
si tiene
[Música]
qué bonito
la lleve
si te
[Aplausos]
[Música]
madre
i
[Música]
con ser
ah
a
él
i
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sois libres
[Música]
dejais ser libres
quiero que lo penséis por un momento
[Música]
la forma
no
[Música]
y más
o no
[Música]
nada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
un poco
i
es alguna de mis palabras favoritas
un día porque ese significado en el
diccionario
y decía
he estado condición de que no es el agua
y yo me pregunte
y esclavo de qué
esclavo de nuestro miedo
o esclavo del que dirá
o esclavos de nuestro falso yo perdona
a mi corta edad no paro de escuchar
comentarios negativos juzgando
comportamiento formas de ser mucho
género colores bla bla bla
no
estoy creciendo en una educación que
está basada en el respeto y el amor y
aquí y ahora aprovecho para dar las
gracias a mi padre ya mi hermana
porque ellos me dejan ser y eso es lo
que yo intento transmitir cuando cantó y
bailó en ese momento yo me siento libre
somos creatividad no te cierre
porque tener miedo a descubrirnos o
porque etiquetar
con lo fácil que respetar actuemos
para pensar
coged vuestra imaginación y darle alas
yo cuando lo hago
cojo mis espada
y soy el guerrero más grande de la
galaxia
otras veces
cojo mi peluca en mis plataformas
y soy la diva con más glamour como acaba
de comprobar ahora
sin embargo otra vez quiero ver el
personaje desde otro punto de vista
así que cojo mi blog mis colores y
empieza a dibujar ya crear
llénate de poderes fluye sé feliz
y sobre todo deja ser al ser que llevas
dentro
muchas gracias a ustedes málaga un
besito y hasta siempre